Hi, I'm Christopher Simone and I'm the Scoutmaster of Troop 71 in Plendome, New
York. This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now to you, Scoutmaster.
You've heard this saying before: where there's smoke, there's fire. Obviously,
whoever said that was not a Scoutmaster.
Hey, this is podcast number 243..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag and see who we've heard from.
Oh, this one is. This is pretty cool.
Shulingela Philippus got in touch with us
And Shulingela is a scouter in Namibia.
Where's Namibia, you ask?
Well, I had to check up. I know it's a country in Africa,
but it's on the western coast of the southern part of Africa,
near the nation of South Africa.
But Shulingela got in touch to say
we're all Scouters in the world movement and we share prayers for each other-
And we certainly do.
And thanks for getting in touch,
Shulingela. you're the first Scouter from Namibia to say hello.
Lyle Lindau is with Cub Scout Pack 56 in Bonn, Germany.
He wrote in to say thanks for your site and the weekly podcast.
I started serving as Cub Master for Pack 56 here in Germany
and found your articles and discussions very useful,
especially to bring me up to speed on Scouting Today,
having last been a Scout in the early 1980s,
And Lyle went on to say that he was having a problem
with the Scout Master CG app on iOS 8..
A number of you got in touch to say
that you were having problems with the app on iOS 8..
Well, hopefully it's fixed and working flawlessly now.
Make sure to update it or try reloading it,
but we should be in good shape.
If you continue to have problems, get in touch and we'll get it fixed.
We're from Jerry Curry.
He said your podcast on leadership elections was very timely.
It's been six or seven years since we have more than one candidate
for Senior Patrol Leader.
I worked with our Senior Patrol Leader to come up with a plan.
The candidates gave a two-minute speech,
He handed out ballots,
We counted them and he announced the final results.
It all worked perfectly.
Jerry, that sounds great.
I'm glad we were able to help.
I will say that we have agents everywhere
and I try my best to time things for what's happening
in each one of the troops out there.
Heard from Dan Marner about last week's podcast.
He said you told us on the podcast that the guidelines
for the PAC Overnighter site approval form
apply to Weeblers Den Camping.
We discussed this at Bulu Training
and the Cub Scout Outdoor Program guidelines
make a pretty clear delineation
between PAC Overnighters and Weeblers Den Camping.
I differ with your conclusion that the site approval standards
for PACs apply to Weeblers Den Camping.
I'm hoping the new Cub Program coming next year
clarifies a lot of that language.
I followed your blog for a long time
but just started listening to the podcast.
Keep up the great work.
You provide an invaluable resource.
Well thanks, Dan.
I appreciate your help with that.
If anybody has the official verbiage
that describes those differences,
I'd be happy to alert everybody to where they can find them.
If you were listening last week,
hopefully I didn't add to anybody's confusion about this,
And I'll take a moment to say
I do my best to get questions of official policy right
and I use the resources that are available to me.
I would never recommend that you take my word as gospel.
You always want to make sure that you back up
your understanding of any of these policy-type questions
by looking at all of the resources
and the literature that's been provided for you
Over on the blog. this week
I published the first and second chapters of a story
that follows a new scout master-
and I'm calling him Chuck Grant,
who is attempting to use the patrol method
in a troop. that's kind of forgotten how to do that.
Now I've based this work of fiction-
and it is a work of fiction-
on the stories that have been shared with me
by readers and listeners
and the questions they've asked
and the advice I usually commonly share and reply.
What I'm hoping is
is that the kind of narrative format of a story
will help you kind of get into the spirit of things
and to understand and how to take the principles
that we talk about and actually apply them.
and giving examples of conversations that go on
and events and things like that
I think maybe will help to illuminate how that works.
And I've tried to avoid being unreasonably optimistic
or overly pessimistic
and being as realistic with some of the challenges
and setbacks we're all going to encounter
in being scouters.
So the plan is to publish a series of 12 chapters
in this story
and they're going to be published
each Tuesday and Thursday at scoutmastercgcom-
Look for the post titled
A New Scout Master-
And a lot of you got in touch about that series.
Luke Koch commented
there's really good stuff here.
can't wait for the next chapter,
Michael Lody's said
I seriously think you should put this together
as an audio play,
and so did Michael Meninger.
He said I could see this acted out.
It's well written.
Well, it'll be written for now, folks,
but maybe you know in the future, who knows?
Heard from Andy Denunzio about it.
He said: as a unit commissioner,
I'm sharing the story with
a new scoutmaster.
Thank you for this.
It's a big help.
Mark Nable got in touch to say
I am taking on a new role as scoutmaster
and I'm looking to getting the troop
to a youth led level.
Bill Daniel wrote in to say:
Clark, I love the story.
We just did a restart in my troop
and I'm going to use this
with the assistant scoutmasters
to kind of draw them into the Baden Powell fold.
I will let you and the blog
do some of the heavy lifting
and take a break.
Well, we live to serve Bill.
I hope it all helps.
John Nelson said good luck to Chuck,
the scoutmaster in the story,
who will be giving a better experience
to their scouts.
And Mark Edwards wrote in
to say it was a great read.
So do check that out
at scoutmastercgcom.
It's called a new scoutmaster.
Like I said, we plan on 12 installments
to the story published
every Tuesday and Thursday.
So if you're a regular reader and listener
and if the resources we've created
have helped you,
you can return the favor
by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer,
And the funds we get from backers
go towards the expenses
of producing and publishing
the blog posts and the podcasts
and everything else
that are resources available
to scouts all over the world.
Hey, I heard from Namibia this week
and from Bonn, Germany,
So it does get out there.
It's easy to become a backer.
Go to scoutmastercgcom.
Look for the support link in the menu
at the very top of the page.
You can choose any level of support
and they're all appreciated.
Some of them entitle you to premiums,
like autograph copies of my book
And this week
let me take a moment to personally thank
Jackie Reese,
who became a backer
since our last podcast.
Go to scoutmastercgcom,
Become a backer this week
and I'll be sure to thank you
on our next podcast.
So in this podcast
we've got tons of email questions to answer
And I have some thoughts
about the context of scouting
in scoutmastership in seven minutes or less,
And that will take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes
or less.
I want to talk about two types
of questions that I get quite often,
because they really share a common answer,
and that is, you know,
the context of scouting.
Let me see if I can explain what I mean.
I'll get a question like this:
What if our patrol leaders council decided
to cancel all the troop meetings
for the next two months?
I mean that is boy-led, right.
Or what if our patrol leaders council voted
and they decide that the next six months
of trips we're going to take
are all going to be visits
to the local amusement parks?
I mean we are a boy-led.
If they make the decision,
we should follow it, right?
However, our patrol leaders council decided
that, instead of having elections,
the adults should appoint
the senior patrol leader.
I mean they are making the decision
and we are youth-led,
so we should accept that decision, right?
I think the first point I want to make-
and I don't want to be really pedantic about this,
but let me observe
that we don't work with boys,
We work with scouts, right?
I know it sounds like I'm splitting hairs,
but there's actually a really important distinction
there that answers this question.
We don't have boys leading anything.
We don't have boys in our patrol leaders council,
We only have scouts,
And I say this because it's important
to consistently express and reinforce the message
that scouts lead themselves
within the context of the scouting program.
That's why I think it's important
to think of them as scouts rather than boys.
I mentioned this kind of thing in a recent podcast,
but I think it bears repeating.
The kind of recursive loop of logic
that says anything that the boys decide
is therefore youth leadership.
it's missing a few important foundational concepts.
By now. you've probably grown tired
of my frequent sports analogies,
but I think it really works here.
Does a basketball team get to vote on the rules
or the constraints of the game?
Well, no, they don't have a vote on that.
You have the rules and constraints
and the context of the game
and you play the game with basketball.
So the purpose and achievement that we get out of scouting
doesn't come from simple, unfettered freedom
that we can make any decision that we want to make.
There are constraints and contexts
that define the types of decisions
that scouts make.
In scouting. our defining constraint
is the nature of the program
and the policies and procedures
that help define the nature of the program.
And these constraints aren't negative,
not by a long shot.
They're actually very positive
and they're inspiring.
I would say that creativity and innovation
comes from, in part,
the constraints of the question, don't they?
So we work within a set of constraints
and in a context called scouting.
We're not led by boys,
we're led by scouts.
The decisions that they make
have to be based on the context and the constraints.
That's just the rules of the game.
I said there were two questions that I get frequently
that have the same answer.
so, along the same lines,
I'm frequently asked how I'd react
if, as I suggest, scouts are having, say,
and how they make up their own patrols.
What if there's a scout
that nobody wants in their patrol?
And the answer is always the same:
As scouts were constrained,
right to act within
the oath and law
in everything,
No other rules are required.
We don't want to make other rules.
All we need to do is be champions
of the scout oath and law.
Scouts follow the oath and law.
They're not concerned with popularity
or who they like and who they don't like.
They're concerned with serving
their fellow scouts.
Now, sometimes boys
need to think through
what it means to be
a scout.
So let's say that a boy tells us:
I don't want to be in a patrol with that guy.
He's just kind of a pain.
So your answer would be:
well, what part of the scout oath and law
describes rejecting a fellow scout
because you think he's a pain?
So every boy,
no matter how painful or unpopular,
gets to be
a scout.
We accept him as he is
when we practice the scout oath and law.
Now I understand that there are
friendships between scouts
and those friendships are very important.
But there's also something broader that happens
when we practice the scout oath and law:
that a scout is a friend
to every other scout.
That certainly doesn't mean
that every other scout is their favorite.
But if the oath and law is to mean
anything at all,
no scout certainly is an enemy
of another scout
And no scout is
thereby going to be deemed unpopular.
Now this all sounds kind of glib
and unrealistic, but I know,
just as you do, that boys sometimes
find it challenging
to be scouts.
So that's where it's our responsibility:
to champion the oath and law
as the basis of everything
that we do and all the decisions
that they make. If you work at this,
there's no questions
about popularity. There's
no room for marginalizing a scout
based on whether other boys
like him or not.
Boys may do that,
but scouts never would.
So we
champion the scout oath and law.
We speak about it all the time.
We talk with our patrol leaders council.
We discuss how the oath and law applies
to everything that they do and all the decisions
that they make. We work through some scenarios.
I would sit down and ask my patrol
leaders council and I have frequently
what if nobody wants a scout in their patrol?
How are you going to deal with that
And the ensuing discussion?
we're able to talk about the oath and law.
We're able to talk about the difference just being
a boy somewhere and being a scout,
and I'm able to encourage them
to make it a point of pride in their troop
that everyone is accepted
and treated as a friend
And that way there's never a question of leaving
anybody out when it comes time
to reorganize patrols or to elect
leaders or something like that.
We create a culture of the scout
oath and law. So two questions
with a common answer.
We work within the context of
scouting and that disallows
these theoretically kind of
nutty decisions that a group
of boys might make, but
scouts never would. And we work
within the context of the scout
oath and law. It describes
our attitude and how we
do things. So,
within the context of the oath and law,
it's possible for a scout
to be unpopular, to have no friends,
And that's what we aspire to.
There's bumps, setbacks and challenges
along the way, to be sure,
But if we champion the scout oath and law
and we constantly remind
our scouts of the context
that they're playing the game in,
things will go well and you'll create
a culture of scouting in
your troop where these questions
find automatic answers.
Oh, I'm in love with the man who loves to camp.
He camps when it's sunny.
He camps when it's damp. All he needs
is a tent, a sleeping roll,
a package of hot dogs and a sack of charcoal.
He camps in the desert. He camps
in the snow. He says, baby, come
with me,
Find me a letter,
Send it by name.
Email. that is, folks.
And here's an answer to
one of your emails.
So we're going to see if we can crowd
five answers to email questions
into this podcast.
The first question comes from Kathy
Montana in Colorado. She said
last night I had the honor
of being a member of an Eagle border review.
Being asked to serve in this role
got me thinking about other young men
who will be having their Eagle
boards in the next few months.
It occurred to me I had helped out for a few hours
with one of their service projects
and perhaps that I shouldn't serve
on their board. However,
last evening, two members of the border review
had assisted the scout who
was being reviewed with his Eagle project.
I've not been able to find any
guidance on the matter in the guide to advancement,
So maybe I'm seeing
a conflict of interest where there really is none.
Well, first of all, Kathy,
here's a gold star
for checking the guide to advancement
2013.. Good for you.
Everybody should do that. Everybody should
have a copy. Everybody should read it.
Sometimes we get direction from what
isn't said in the policies
as much as from what is said,
And the guide to advancement
is very specific and doesn't explicitly
prohibit people who've
helped with an Eagle project
in sitting on the Eagle
border review, So there's no
policy preventing those persons
from being part of a border review.
If there was a possible issue there,
I can about guarantee you
that it would be
specifically addressed in the guide to advancement,
Because when you read about
the composition of boards of review in general
and Eagle boards of review in particular,
the only real prohibition
on who can't and can't
serve on them is parents
of the scout unit leaders
and their assistants. These are
demonstrable conflicts of
interest. Now, all that being said,
I understand what you're concerned about.
I would say that probably 95 out
of 100 Eagle boards of review
are uncontested approvals of the
scout's work and care. It's a pretty easy
decision to make. What would really
concern me, if there's a conflict of
negative interest or somebody who
is dead set against the scout becoming
an Eagle sitting on their border review-
and yes, that does happen-
I'd be a little suspect of anyone who
requested specifically they be
included in Eagle border review.
It would cause me to ask why
they wanted to do that and see if there was
some kind of hidden agenda anywhere.
Your own conscience comes into play too.
I mean, if you worked on a particular
project that positively or negatively
affected your opinion of the scout
unreasonably. you know,
maybe he was just kind of insufferable
in the way that teenagers can be, sometimes
No real problem,
but you just really didn't kind
of like the scout. You can certainly
recuse yourself from serving on his
board if you were invited to do so.
Otherwise, I don't see any
automatic conflict of interest and I think
if it was, it would be mentioned
specifically in the Guide to Advancement.
Mark is the scout master
of Troop 18 in the cross, Wisconsin.
He said: I am a scout master
trying to get our troop
applying the patrol method. I don't
want to direct the scouts, but
guide, like you recommend.
how can I best tell
when I should offer advice
and when I am intruding?
Well, Mark, that is a great question,
and the first step is understanding
that it's possible.
what you may have to say or
advise is interfering
with your youth leadership.
So that you understand
that that's even possible
puts you way ahead of a lot of scout masters.
My best advice is
that when you are telling scouts
something or giving directions,
you're in danger of running
over them a little bit
and you're not really using the opportunity
optimally to inspire
their thought process as an initiative.
If you ask questions, though,
you're encouraging them to
find answers. If you get good
at asking questions that help them find the way,
you'll have less chance
of interfering. All that being said,
you're working with individual scouts
who have individual abilities. right,
some are going to require being told
at times. some will do
a lot better with going through
a series of questions. some
will need little or no input from you at all.
they'll figure it out on their own,
and some will need a whole lot of help
getting there. It's a very
inexact science. You have to be
patient with yourself and with your
scouts. If you get frustrated,
share those frustrations with them and ask for some help.
and while we're doing serious work
with our scouts, on one hand,
you have to carry it out in a spirit of fun
and good humor. We never
actually arrive at a resting place
as scout leaders where we can
proclaim that we've done it
and everything is working perfectly.
We have our moments to be sure,
but it's all about the process and the journey.
Mark got back to say:
this really helps and reinforces
what I'm already doing. I'm committed
to letting our scouts go about
their process of finding things out,
but I'm going to be fighting parents
all the way because, myself included,
we really cleave to the notion
that things should run smoothly.
I certainly understand that.
but Mark went on to say:
I embraced the chaos when I was a teenager
and I can do it again.
and thank you for the four part essays you have
on the patrol method and the adult role.
they're awesome. Well, Mark,
I'm really glad that we're able to help you there.
The next question comes from Conquista Bush,
who asks:
if a scout earns a merit badge
that has the exact same requirements
as a rank requirement,
has the scout met the
requirement for both the badge
and the rank?
As an example, my son earned
the first aid merit badge.
The first aid merit badge, requirement number one,
says: show what to do
for hurry cases of stock breathing
and internal poisoning, which is the same
as second class requirements 7a.
If the scout
earned the merit badge,
the work that he did for the merit badge
be considered a completion
of the rank requirement.
my son scout master is requesting
that he demonstrate these things again
and I don't understand why.
Welcome Conquista, let's see if we can
unwrap this a little bit.
The first requirement for
first aid merit badge reads,
quote: satisfy your counselor.
you have current knowledge of all first aid requirements
for tender foot, second class
and first class ranks.
Now I suppose ideally
what would happen is
that the rank requirements would have been
signed off to begin with
before your son started first aid merit badge.
but apparently he's doing the merit badge
first and that is
absolutely fine. by the way,
there's nothing that says he has to have
those requirements first,
because if you look at the wording of the requirement.
it says: satisfy your counselor that you have
current knowledge of these requirements-
not that they're signed off,
but that you have current knowledge of them.
Now, when it comes to whether or not
the work he did for the merit badge
automatically counts towards the rank
requirement or vice versa
it doesn't-
he's earning two separate badges
and the requirements are being tested by two
different people.
it's really the choice of the person
who is testing your son on the rank
requirement whether or not
they'll accept the work done for the merit badge
and vice versa
rank requirements. it would be up to
the merit badge counselor whether they would accept
that work and he would have
to do exactly what the requirements said.
he would have to satisfy the counselor
that he has current knowledge of those
rank requirements. and how
the counselor chose do that is basically up to
the counselor. testing and requirements
for scouting is more than
you know. I did that once a long time ago.
or I did it for a rank
or I did it for a merit badge. it's based
on the knowledge that the scout demonstrates
at the time he's tested. think
of it this way: some of the courses that
you'll take in college will cover the same
subject you studied in high school.
some college professors may accept
your high school work, some may not.
it's up to them to be sure that they've
done their due diligence to assure
themselves you have the knowledge
before you pass their course
correct. and I think that's an apt
parallel to what we're talking about here.
you have two different badges, two different
people applying the test to
the requirements and it's up to them
to do their due diligence to make sure that
the requirements fulfilled. and
any scout with the merit badge
should be able to demonstrate the knowledge
for the rank requirements pretty easily. so it shouldn't
be a big deal for all that time
consuming and I would also say
I think it's great practice, right.
so next question comes from Stu Jackson,
who is with troop
212 in North Glen
Colorado, and Stu wrote in
to say I've thoroughly enjoyed the resources you
put together and I've come to look at
scoutmastercgcom as a trusted old friend
who's ready to talk scouting whenever I
am. I've been given the opportunity to
become the next scout master of our troop.
without your insight and ideas
I'd probably be sitting in a corner rocking
back and forth and mumbling to myself
about knots.
you know that's a
pick. that's this pretty strong picture right
there in my mind. I've- I think I've felt
that way several times as a scout master
myself. anyway, Stu goes on
to say our troop has adopted
that dreaded, nice and neat idea
of balanced patrols. I've asked
why, and the answer's been:
well, that's the way we've always done it.
after looking at a troop from a scouts
perspective and doing an enormous amount of research,
I presented the idea to our parents
and committee that we should have
the scouts creating their own patrols.
most seem to accept the idea
but, as you'd expect, there's a few that seem to
waver a little bit and to me
it's something completely understandable since
changing the way we've become accustomed to.
as I work with the youth leadership
to make our patrol change as possible,
a couple of questions has come up
and I was wondering if I could get your thoughts.
the current ideas is that we will let the boys
meet together to work to form
their own patrols without any sort of assistance
in the form of an adult
or the senior patrol leader, unless a problem
or a question arises. my concern
is what happens if a scout
doesn't naturally fit into patrol
during that process. I want to avoid
hurting the feelings of scouts in that situation
and there will be a scout master
minute with some point on including everybody.
additionally, I'm also planning
on a few strategic discussions with the
scouts identified as natural leaders
to help facilitate avoiding the alienation
of any of the boys.
have you faced instances like that and in those
cases, what have you done? I found
on your site some different resources
for forming a patrol, using a form
to indicate three of your friends and having
the senior patrol leader put the patrols together.
based on that info, that seems
to differ with some of your other material
that gives the idea that boys should get a shot
at creating their own patrols.
is this just another option? have your
opinions of patrol formation changed
during your experience as scout master?
I touched on some of this a little bit earlier
in scout master ship in seven minutes or less,
but there's no really one
right way to get this done.
there's just lots of good ways, like making coffee,
right. you know some people will say
that you have to do it exactly this way
and some people say you do it another way,
but at the end you have a cup
of coffee. that's what's important. your
scouts elected their senior patrol leader
and that means that they have a measure of trust
and respect for him. so
he's the lead man on who
goes and what patrol. your role
as scout master is helping him figure out
how that works. so does he thinks things
should be changed? on what does he base
this opinion? as he asked the patrol leaders
and the other scouts about what they think?
will he ask scouts
what patrol they like to be in? how will
we ask him? how important does he think
it is to know about those things?
once he's asked the scouts, well,
what exactly happened next? will he
make up patrols on his own? will he
want some help from people? how is he
going to administer that process?
what happens if we have a scout nobody
wants in their patrol? and, like I said,
it talked about this earlier in the podcast-
all of this has to be conducted
according to the scout oath and law right
and the senior patrol leader has to
consider how to make this happen in the spirit
of friendliness, kindness and courtesy to
all the scouts. so how,
step by step, does he
think he wants to accomplishment? and as
you and the senior patrol leader discuss
the answers to all these questions,
the strategy begins to form.
you're helping him figure things out, not
really directing him to do anything
specific. you're just asking questions
and when it's all done,
it's basically his idea. what
the other adults think about it,
you know I'm going to say, is kind of
peripherally important and in a way
it's kind of none in their business. these are decisions
that the scout should be able to work
with and to make with your oversight
and your advice. the scouts elected
their senior patrol leader, ought to be able to lead
and he needs to lead within the context,
in the spirit of scouting as we've talked about.
your job is going to be supplying
that context. and you also
ask the question about the
idea where scouts write down three
of the guys they want
to be in a patrol with as a way
to help the senior patrol leader make those
decisions. the other advice
that you mentioned that I give
about letting them work it out- it doesn't
really conflict with that. it's just
several different,
equal approaches to
sorting out patrols.
in a small troop of 10,
12, 15 scouts,
sorting out patrols probably only takes
a few minutes. in a much larger
troop, you may want to use the other method
that I suggest
about getting the scouts to write
down three guys they want to be in a patrol
with. you know, or you're
going to come up with a totally different method, but
the principles are all the same, are they
that this should be a
youth led decision and they should
be heavily invested in making these
decisions, because this is their
troop and their patrols.
Rob Landquist is with troop 4
in Waukesha, Wisconsin,
and he wrote in to say this. when a
scout finishes the requirements for a rank
in our troop normally comes to me for
a scout master conference
and then they go to this committee chair,
who are really there at about every
single meeting and and are able to hold
boards of review, basically right after
the scout is done with a conference,
unless it's too late in the meeting,
and then if the scout hasn't asked them
for a border review, they'll ask at the next
meeting. so in the scenario that I
described there, the scouts not
required to ask for a border review.
they just have the option to ask for it
before they're asked, because they're going
to the advancement chairman directly
after they're done with me and they're asking for their board.
I'm a little concerned about this because
of the discussion that's been going on
about the policy and the guide to
advancement as it concerns
scouts requesting a border
review. well, Rob, I think
I think crossing the room to ask
the advancement chair for a border review
doesn't sound like a roadblock to
me. right, it sounds like what happens
when I finish a scout master conference.
most of the time, you know, I tell
the scout to go see Mrs so and so,
over there, let her know
that you're ready for a border review-
pretty simple. unfortunately,
some troops are in the habit of making that
simple process much more difficult
and complicated, making it into
some kind of roadblock or
additional challenge that constitutes
an addition to the requirements for the
rank. it sounds to me like you guys
get it that you understand the spirit
of the whole thing, that this aspect
of advancement, of expecting
scouts to go request a border review
in some official manner, fill out
a form or something like that,
it's simply not their responsibility
to do so. the advancement chair
should be active and involved and they
should be monitoring the advancement of scouts and
they should know when they need a border review.
but you know, crossing the room to talk
to the advancement chair, that doesn't constitute
an additional requirement
and it doesn't constitute a roadblock, from what
I can see. I hope the answers to those
questions have helped you. I want to reiterate
something is very, very important:
what you're hearing, especially when it comes to
specific policy questions
and rules, is my
best take on exactly what's going on.
I back this up by checking the references
and resources that are available to us,
but never, ever, just
take my word for it. go to the
resources, go to the materials that are
provided to us and make
sure that I've got it right. I'm capable
of being just as wrong as anybody else,
so if there's any point
to any of this at all, it should
be that we're always questioning, we're always
asking about what we assume
is the right way to do things,
and we're backing that up by going to the
resources and the literature that's
provided to us and making sure that
we've got the right end of the stick.
now, if you've got a question for me,
I would love to have you get in touch,
and you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
music,
hey. thanks so much for listening to this
243rd edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how to keep in touch.
you can read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive an email every time the blog is updated,
or you can get a weekly digest
of new posts to the blog.
you can join the 4,000 or so other mobile
scouts who have the scoutmastercg app
on their mobile devices.
you can get the app on google play
or at the itunes app store.
you can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama
of social media outlets.
join the 6900 folks who like
scoutmaster blog on facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of 1200
tweeters on twitter. pin the
pultritudinous pictures proffered publicly
with 1,800 other prolific
pinners on pinterest.
watch us at scoutmastercg on youtube
or
join the 400 odd folks who form
the exclusive scoutmastercg circle
on google plus.
now, if you can't face facebook,
if twitter makes you better, if you have no interest in pinterest,
if you don't put the? u in youtube
and if you're a minus when it comes to google plus,
well, that's alright. bunkie,
zoom into the late 90s and
fire off an email.
email me clarkgreen
comments and questions and other wild ideas you might have
at clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
that's c, l, a,
r, k, e.
at
scoutmastercgcom,
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the boy scouts of america,
nor they endorsed or sponsored by the boy scouts of america.
no, it's just me
talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and we're not sponsored or endorsed by
any scouting organization,
because I'm sure they all have better things
to do with their time.
nope, let's have a little fun now.
here's our founder, Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir?
until next time, everyone.